hey David I've heard a lot of people say
everyone is a little bit racist that
seems like a very dangerous proposition
to me and a way to justify racism what
do you think so let's start with with
the phrase right everyone is a little
bit racist it's a very often repeated
phrase what do we even mean by that
right what does it mean everyone is a
little bit racist does that mean if you
were to have a racism test that you
could give to individuals like a blood
test or a vision test would everyone get
results that say you're at least a
little bit racist are we saying that it
is at the individual level are we saying
that societally everybody's a little bit
racist this is actually kind of an
important thing when I say that we all
Harbor if we exist in society and
culture preconceived notions prejudices
prejudgments inherent biases about
people on the basis of their race age
gender other characteristics and traits
I am NOT saying that every individual is
racist in what they believe should be
the organizing principles of society so
let me give you an example of that you
can have an individual who believes in
racial equality and racial justice and
believes that we should be working to
support individuals who have been
historically oppressed by the structure
of society and that same person might
unknowingly make pre judgments about
people when they see that someone is
Asian or when they see that somebody is
black or that they are a brown skinned
Latino for example that is very very
different than saying that's the same as
a white nationalist
and that's where I think that the phrase
is an important one in that it is
accurate that we all really do have
these these preconceived notions because
we exist in society and we observe the
world and the people around us and
that's sort of what stereotyping is and
all
allows us to do which is you can't know
everybody in the world so on a
subconscious level and some people on a
conscious level start to group
individuals to try to ascertain or
deduce things about them without
actually knowing them it's sort of a
natural and obvious thing that the human
brain would do the problem is when it
becomes destructive discriminatory and
toxic so if you want to have a
conversation about how everybody likely
I would argue undeniably has these sort
of implicit biases I'm right there with
you if the idea is to defend racism or
racism in practice because on a scale of
one to ten everybody places somewhere in
terms of that implicit bias then I do
think that it is dangerous and I also by
the way think that it's inaccurate
because having implicit biases and in
particular recognizing that you have
them is very very different than being
the type of separatist nationalist
extremists that we've seen coalesced
under the trump administration for
example or any other type of racism send
me your thoughts I want to hear from you
about this everybody is just a little
bit racist logical potentially dangerous
combination of both something else let
me know we've got a great bonus show for
you today
get access by becoming a member at WWE
Ackman calm or by becoming a patron for
as little as $5 a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show